wenn es kracht oder brennt sind sie da
die kamerateams von nonstopnews 80
reporter in ganz deutschland sorgen
dafür dass fernsehsender aktuelle videos
für die nachrichten bekommen sie
dokumentieren jeden tag dramatische
rettungsaktionen tragische geschichten
und manchmal auch kuriose szenen
[Musik]
der konkurrenzkampf ist groß
hat kein bild der welt ist es wert sich
selber da irgendwie in gefahr zu geben
wie funktioniert die arbeit an
unfallstellen zwischen feuerwehr und
polizei und was unterscheidet die
reporter von gaffern und schaulustigen
bild unterwegs mit dem blaulicht
reportern in niedersachsen
seit 2002 produziert nonstopnews mit
sitz in delmenhorst videomaterial für
fernsehsender das kerngeschäft auto
unfälle brände polizei und feuerwehr
einsätze rund um die uhr sind reporter
in bereitschaft die bei einem hinweis
auf ein ereignis sofort losfahren
genau diese geschwindigkeit ist unsere
stärke dass wir schnell kenntnis von
ereignissen haben schnell von
ereignissen berichten und diese auch
schnell auf sendung bringen einsatz für
reporter peter will
das lässt darauf schließen dass
vermutlich ein eingeklemmtes vielleicht
auch morgen betriebsstoffe aus
was ihn vor ort erwartet weiß peter noch
nicht die anfahrt dauert etwas mehr als
eine halbe stunde
ein auto liegt über kopf im graben die
fahrerin des wagens wurde bereits
weggebracht
peter sammelt erste bilder von der
unfallstelle
einsatzfahrzeuge das verunfallte auto
die umgebung feuerwehrleute solange er
niemanden behindert kann er sich frei
bewegen die meisten einsatzkräfte sind
reporter gewohnt
ein verantwortlicher feuerwehrmann
ordnet den einsatz vor der kamera ein
nachdem drei liter reporter das material
noch vor ort auf die server der agentur
dafür ist extra ein laptop im
einsatzwagen installiert und 1 5 g
module für eine schnelle
internetverbindung das erste bild von
vor ort
als letztes der anruf in der zentrale
geld bekommt peter für diesen einsatz
nur wenn seine videos ausgestrahlt
werden was die sender bezahlen wird
zwischen ihm und der agentur aufgeteilt
kaufen die sender nicht oder bei der
konkurrenz geht der reporter leer aus
das wird die schlagzeile sein mit der er
sein material den sendern angeboten wird
peugeot kommt von landstraße ab
überschlägt sich und landet kopfüber in
seitengraben
die nonstopnews zentrale in delmenhorst
hier laufen alle geschichten zusammen
alexander hahn sichtet die eingehenden
videos und schreibt die angebote für die
fernsehsender
ja kein problem das wird jetzt 16 uhr
ist der termin und die kollegin lädt das
dann hoch dann könnte das sofort
herunterladen
meldungen können zu jeder zeit entstehen
auch an sonn und feiertagen deshalb ist
die die erreichbarkeit die telefonische
erreichbarkeit das wichtigste das
material kaufen fast alle sender unfälle
oder brennende laufen je nach ausmaß im
regionalprogramm oder in der tagesschau
aber auch online medien haben einen
immer größeren bedarf an videos
den richtigen draht zu den sendern haben
darum kümmert er sich
1900 während schröder gerhard schröder
hat nonstopnews gegründet heute fährt er
nicht mehr regelmäßig selbst raus aber
er hat alle einsätze im blick
telefoniert mit den sendern und sorgt
dafür dass sein material nicht übersehen
wird mal ganz kurz auf das noch hochlädt
konnte die persönliche verbindung ist
ihm wichtig nicht nur mit den sendern
sondern auch mit den einsatzkräften
ich möchte nicht der unbekannte blaues
reporter sein der einfach anonym
irgendwo hinfährt irgendwelche bösen
bilder macht und einfach wieder
verschwindet ich möchte vertrauen
schaffen ich möchte diesen job
eigentlich nur dann machen wenn ich
sicher sein kann dass ich mit einem
guten ruf für nach hause gehen kann je
größer der einsatz sie spektakulärer die
bilder desto besser verkaufen sie sich
aber es gibt klare grenzen für die
reporter alles das was nachher nicht
gezeigt werden darf sprich leichen
schwerstverletzte irgendwie close ups
und so weiter werden gar nicht erst
gefilmt wofür es wäre fatal wenn wir mit
themen heraus kommen bevor angehörige
bescheid wissen dass etwas passiert ist
dass wir nicht wirklicher weise dort er
irgendwie bescheid geben als dass die
polizei möglicherweise auch diese
angehörigen benachrichtigt
22 uhr 30 zwischen bad zwischenahn und
oldenburg für reporter kai strömer
beginnt die nachtschicht mit einem
schwertransport
ein altes schiff wird nach oldenburg
gebracht wo es später zu einem
restaurant umgebaut werden soll für den
transport wurde es extra in zwei hälften
gesägt sonst wäre es zu breit gewesen
zwei stunden fahrt sind für den ersten
teil des schiffes heute eingeplant
spektakuläre bilder aus der region
der reporter von nonstopnews ist nicht
der einzige so ein spektakel lassen sich
auch die anderen nachrichtenagenturen
nicht entgehen umso wichtiger die besten
bilder zu bekommen
da müssen wir mal gucken wo wir jetzt am
besten fahren wir kommen ja nicht an dem
schwertransporter vorbei hinterherfahren
ist auch blöd dass ich genauso wie beim
unwetter und wer da hinterher fahren
dann meistens nichts abfahrt im original
polizeiauto aus den usa den dodge
charger von kai strömer von bis vor
kurzem noch polizisten in texas der
reporter hat glück und wird an dem
schwertransport vorbeigelassen
seit zwei jahren ist krömer bei
nonstopnews in der regel übernimmt er
die nachtschichten dann arbeitet er von
23 uhr bis morgens um 7
der reporter hat zwar gute bilder vom
vorbeifahren aber jetzt ist der hinter
dem transport eigentlich die schlechtere
position überholen ist hier auf der
autobahn nicht möglich doch plötzlich
hält der transport an
gekonnt
umgehen gekommen
mit so einem zwischenfall hatte niemand
gerechnet von anderen reportern keine
spur sie warten an anderen positionen
auf den konvoi und verpassen die
kritischen momente exklusive bilder für
kai strömer
[Applaus]
nach wenigen momenten geht es weiter
zurück bleibt eine furche in der brücke
nur auf kamera bei krömer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der schwertransport ist kurz vor dem
ziel in oldenburg doch plötzlich drehte
reporter ab
am ende aber
es kann ja auch nicht außer acht lassen
und um sicherzugehen dass es nichts für
uns müssen wir uns an gruppen
da abgeben
[Musik]
krömer trifft zusammen mit der zweite
polizeistreife vor ort ein der unfall
passierte auf einer landstraße die lage
vor ort auf den ersten blick ruhig
wir wissen nur dass ein auto verunfallt
ist mit drei personen die sind jetzt
auch mittlerweile schon alle weg gelten
erstmals leicht verletzt und jetzt ist
gerade die polizei dabei und machte die
unfallaufnahme und guckt wie es passiert
ist daher dem jemand ein bisschen zurück
dass ich nicht im weg stehe aber die
bilder die wir kriegen können die kommen
schon mal die schon mal anfangen
ist die frage was jetzt hinter der
geschichte steht jetzt irgendwie
tatsächlich irgend jemand ausgewichen
ist oder ob eben was anderes dazu
geführt hat dass es zu dem unfall kam
dass es jetzt hier das entscheidende
bildlich das ist jetzt nicht mehr so
viel dann warten doch die
pressemitteilung vielleicht das
irgendwie drogen im spiel gewesen
alkohol im spiel gewesen das war mal
schauen dann erst mal wartete reporter
aber auf den abschlepper der lässt sich
diese nachtzeit mehr als zwei stunden
wird krömer am ende vor ort sein
deutlich länger als üblich
alles sein kann haben uns jetzt auch die
zeit genommen noch das bild mit
einzufangen und jetzt rücken wir ab
bei unfällen filmen mit der kamera
zwischen den einsatzkräften stehen geld
damit verdienen wenn anderen menschen
schreckliche dinge passieren
diese arbeit bleibt nicht ohne kritik
während gassen und filmen an
einsatzstellen hart bestraft wird dürfen
die blaulicht reporter ungehindert und
ohne angst vor einer strafe unfälle und
brände filmen wie passt das zusammen
wir bemühen uns hier auch da wird zu
berichten damit eben nicht so viel läuft
er selber sich vor ort ein bild machen
müssen sondern dass man im grunde in die
medien darüber berichtet dass man im
grunde offiziell berichtet und der große
unterschied ist es wenn wir vor ort
berichten dann filtern wir die
informationen wir filtern sie einerseits
bild licht das heißt wir drehen etwas wo
wir aber genau wissen diese bilder
gehören nicht in die öffentlichkeit da
muss gepixelt werden das muss
zurückhaltung gewahrt werden der
privaten man weiß einfach nicht was für
regel es gibt und welche zu beachten hat
wir wissen dass wir unser beruf ist
ein beruf der auch zur belastung werden
kann meistens beginnt die arbeit der
reporter zwar erst wenn verletzte
bereits versorgt oder abtransportiert
wurden aber eben nicht immer
es gibt natürlich immer auch fälle wo
man auch recht früh da ist man hört
eventuell noch irgendwelche schreie von
unfallopfern oder man erlebt
möglicherweise wo
verletzte abtransportiert werden oder
sogar wo es wäre tote gibt das geht auch
nicht alles an einem vorbei man lernt
aber auch an einsatzstellen damit
umzugehen denn auch bemerkt man dass
auch feuerwehr und polizei lernen müssen
mit solchen situation umzugehen ist
deren alltag und man merkt sehr schnell
dass dann auch vor ort in dem dialog mit
der polizei eine gewisse lockerheit
entsteht um einfach gar nicht diese
diese sache irgendwie sich zu nahe
kommen zu lassen und man baut dadurch
eine gewisse distanz auch zu den themen
auf und macht seine arbeit konzentriert
sich auf endeffekt auch sein auf seinen
suche und auf seinem bild noch seine
arbeit
zurück in der nachtschicht es ist kurz
vor 3 zeit für eine kleine pause krömer
nimmt uns mit in seine ruhe oase
das ist hier in dem dorf wo der unfall
passiert ist das war zufall
das ja aus den 60er jahren eine
tankstelle die habe ich jetzt ungefähr
einem jahr und hab ich mich ein bisschen
hergerichtet und was soll ich schon
bisschen rum dass es so mein ja hier
komme ich runter ganzen acht unfälle
oder verbrechen wurde ich gerade sagen
brände da musste man irgendwas haben wo
man
darunter kommt wieder
hier war früher die waschhalle drinne
von der tankstelle und das habe ich
eingerichtet als werkstatt der britische
oder möbel
da gucke ich doch noch mal hier rein
gucken ob wir noch etwas machen kann
oder was machen möchte umsetzung einfach
noch in kurzen
keine fünf minuten ist der reporter in
seiner tankstelle
da kommt der nächste einsatz rein
der man verschiedene whatsapp gruppen da
hat jemand geschrieben dass mehrere
sirenen in cloppenburg zu hören sind und
da werde ich gleich mal nachschauen was
da los ist aber ich glaube wir können
sie mal in die richtung fahren weil das
sollte irgendwas brennen
so geht's dann waren wir gerade zufällig
in der nähe und jetzt geht es wieder los
die pause wird verschoben
mit feuer kennt sich der 38-jährige aus
seit er zehn jahre alt war ist er selbst
bei der freiwilligen feuerwehr auch
heute fährt er immer wieder als
feuerwehrmann zu einsätzen zum löschen
und ohne kamera schon auf der landstraße
zeigt sich dass die entscheidung richtig
war diesen einsatz anzufahren
ein getränkemarkt brennt die feuerwehr
ist im großeinsatz
plötzlich ein kurioses bild
[Musik]
feuerwehrleute tragen reihenweise beute
aus dem gebäude schaufensterpuppen mit
teuren brautkleidern werden vor den
flammen in sicherheit gebracht
der reporter entdeckt einen lkw-fahrer
er hat die feuerwehr alarmiert erzählt
der mann und er zeigt dem reporter einen
container am nachbarhaus der ebenfalls
gebrannt hat zwei brandorte gleichzeitig
das könnte auf brandstiftung hindeuten
aber das müssen die ermittlungen der
polizei später klären
strömer kann sich frei in der
einsatzstelle bewegen obwohl das gebäude
noch immer brennt seine eigenen
feuerwehr erfahrungen helfen ihm dabei
im weg zu stehen aber weil ich genau
weiß was die machen
die guten beziehungen zur feuerwehr
helfen ihm aber auch darüber hinaus
heute wird er nach dem einsatz diese
aufnahmen der feuerwehr drohne
überspielt bekommen luftaufnahmen direkt
über dem brennenden haus und wärmebilder
so nah wäre er mit seiner eigenen drohne
nie gekommen
hier mehr infos je mehr material desto
besser steht er am ende gegenüber der
konkurrenz dar
mehrere agenturen da ist der
konkurrenzkampf schon ganz groß im
moment wenn ich hier noch alleine machen
wie lange das so ist in dieser nacht
wird er der einzige reporter bleiben
zwischendurch der anruf in der zentrale
dann schickte reporter das material an
die kollegen
hochladen mitten aus der einsatzstelle
das ist auch bei anderen agenturen
mittlerweile standard zu lange würde es
dauern erst zurück in die zentrale zu
fahren
um kurz nach 6 uhr ab das feuer ist
gelöscht die sonne aufgegangen und die
nachtschicht bald vorbei
[Musik]
das war schon eine aufregende nacht muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass es nicht
immer so dass man jetzt von einem
einsatz zum anderen einsatzort es gibt
doch mal phasen wo gar nichts ist oder
nur ein einsatz mittlerweile ist es halb
sieben um 7 uhr ist die nachtschicht
schon wieder zu ende bis wir in der im
ort sind es sieben grunde genommen muss
ich dann nur noch nach hause fahren und
dann vielleicht auch mal ins land gehen
lange kann er allerdings tagsüber auch
nicht schlafen denn er hat viel zu tun
da ist die feuerwehr bei der er als
jugendwart aktiv ist seine tankstelle wo
es immer was zu tun gibt und natürlich
freunde und familie mit denen er
tagsüber was unternimmt
[Musik]
doch ist die
welche sender sein material aus dieser
nacht kaufen und ob er mit seinen
einsätzen geld verdient hat wird er erst
später erfahren
morgens schon wissen was am abend in den
nachrichten läuft und am nächsten tag
vielleicht in der zeitung steht auch das
macht den beruf so besonders erzählt uns
gerd schröder als wir ihn wenige tage
später zum interview treffen alle
verfolgen die nachrichten jeden tag sind
gerade interessiert an aktuellen
geschehnissen ist verfolgt man ja auch
im social media bereich dass gerade
diese aktuellen ereignisse die passieren
unfall rettungsgasse feuer und so weiter
natürlich eine gewisse aufmerksamkeit
auf sich ziehen und wir bedienen diese
das funktioniert ähnlich klingelt das
telefon garrett schröder muss das
interview abbrechen im nachbarort
wildeshausen bahnt sich ein unwetter an
geschäft der zu unterstützung mit raus
massiv gerade schlechter geworden der
schwarze wolken aufgezogen und die
kollegen briefen an das halt wirklich
land unter ist und um unterstützung
gerufen haben das heißt also ich fahre
jetzt der landkreis oldenburg auch das
ist für die reporter normal einsätze
abseits der normalen schichtzeiten auch
wenn sie eigentlich gerade etwas anderes
vorhatte vor wetterlagen habe ich
tierisch respekt also wetter ist schon
schon heftig also wenn es dann so ein
bisschen regen ist ja noch überschaubar
aber ich bin meinen sind die wetterfront
rein gerade so eine chef cloud wo es
wirklich
schlagartig schwarz wie die nacht war es
hat überall geblitzt der wagen hat
gewackelt und ich stand irgendwo mitten
auf dem freien feld da hast du schon
erheblich respektvoll natur und du
kannst nichts machen kein bild der welt
ist es wert sich selber irgendwie in
gefahr zu geben
genau das gleiche haus was da jetzt
gerade ja abgesoffen ist das war schon
mal abgesagt vor ein paar jahren also
man kennt seine meine eltern decken
ungefähr
immer die gleiche ecke hier
ja ja
ein keller steht unter wasser die
feuerwehr muss ihn leer pumpen hier in
der gegend sind die reporter regelmäßig
die feuerwehrleute kennen sie persönlich
plötzlich noch ein bekanntes gesicht
weiter zweiter
wenige tage nachdem wir ihn bei seiner
nachtschicht begleitet haben treffen wir
kai strömer wieder bei so einer lage ist
ja auch tagsüber im einsatz obwohl er
später wieder die nachtschicht
übernehmen wird
und
weiter geht's zum nächsten drehort dem
krankenhaus ein paar straßen weiter
gerrit schröder gibt der zentrale einen
kurzen status also unwetter erledigt
halb so wild ich war noch ein bild und
fahren zurück so dass wir pünktlich um
18 uhr auch dann beim fußball sind
so dass bei ihnen an
ob wir noch bilder kriegen von diesen
schotten und km vor der kennt sich hier
noch besser aus wenn wir aus diesem ort
kommt
und das sind sie die schotten am
krankenhaus sie wurden extra installiert
damit bei solchen wetterlagen die tiefer
liegenden gebäude nicht voll laufen
während die reporter die schotten filmen
kommt die sonne raus das unwetter ist
vorbei
naja aber die trifft vilshofen getroffen
gerrit schröder lädt das material so
schnell wie möglich hoch um es für die
nachrichten noch am selben abend
anzubieten
[Musik]
so
würde sagen
ausser spesen nicht viel gewesen aber so
ist das im geschäft man weiß ja nie was
dann noch so ist und auch das was wir
jetzt gedreht haben reicht ja aus ob es
eventuell irgendwie beim regional
programm unterzubringen es muss ja nicht
immer gleich die breaking news lage sein
die irgendwo das programm unterbricht
also von daher alles scheint
egal was passiert ob feuer unfälle
schwertransporte oder schöne geschichten
aus der region die die menschen bewegen
die reporter versuchen so schnell wie
möglich vor ort zu sein
eines ist nonstopnews gründer gerd
schröder dabei aber immer wichtig
ich wollte immer auch nach außen hin
darstellen dass wir was gutes tun das
für ein wichtiger multiplikator auch
sind für die öffentlichkeitsarbeit von
von polizei und feuerwehr
der kampf um die besten bilder die
ausstrahlung in den nachrichten um am
ende etwas geld auf dem konto zu haben
der beginnt für die reporter jeden tag
aufs neue
[Musik]
[Applaus]